maybe this is news to you but art is
violent man it's selfish i mean i
thought you knew that and who doesn't
love kittens i mean is there a situation
where kittens aren't cool
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna break
down the netflix series brand new cherry
flavor and explain the ending that of
course will include spoilers if you
haven't watched the series yet and now
that i've warned you let's get started
on the surface brand new cherry flavor
is a revenge story about a young
filmmaker coming to la to chase her
dream the protagonist lisa nova played
by rosa salazar in an excellent
performance lays this out for you when
she's asked what the feature version of
her short film would look like this
woman she's got this thing but she
doesn't know how to use it yet the
producer lou burke who i'll introduce in
a second questions if it's like a super
power and she responds yeah but other
people want to take it from her they
want to suck her dry and don't care if
they kill her in the process so this
woman she has to learn how to use this
thing against them if she wants to make
it out alive
she's talking about the character in her
short film lucy's eye but she's also
describing herself she's driven to get
this movie made to see this thing
realized but can't even describe it
really it's this thing coming from
inside of her that she feels compelled
to make real and upon arriving in 90s la
for a meeting with a legit oscar winner
it looks like her dream might come true
i suppose things turning into a
nightmare feels a lot more likely by the
time you see she's being followed by a
mysterious rider on a motorcycle on her
way into the city but even her old
friend code who she calls for a place to
crash says her planned meeting sounds
like a huge opportunity so you can't
blame her for having high hopes
things start off okay lisa is somewhat
out of her depth when she meets with lou
but it seems like her short film might
just be good enough that it doesn't
matter why it's good isn't revealed or
even how it ended up on an assistant's
desk in the first place where lou said
he heard a voice in his head telling him
to pick it up but at the end of their
initial meeting he decides to option her
short and gives her a check for ten
thousand dollars as a deposit in the
beginning it starts off as a mentorship
and to be fair i think the character is
written in a way that he does see
himself as a mentor the problem is the
best part of lou's career has already
passed him by and he's old school in a
sense in that he knows how to continue
to use the power he's accumulated to his
advantage in the business
he's sort of the opposite of her and
that the great ideas that he had and he
was trying to get out and make into a
reality those are gone and now he needs
to capitalize on someone else's
he tells her that he needs her in one of
his most honest moments because he
hadn't had a real hit in almost a decade
and he's so afraid of becoming
irrelevant that he goes straight to
choking lisa out before she can even
finish getting the words washed up out
of her mouth when they have an argument
they got there after things started to
go wrong when he put his hand on her
thigh and then continued to make sexual
advances after she made it clear she
wasn't interested to punish her for
making him feel small he replaced her
with a different director and she
essentially loses her movie when
confronted he says the world we live in
is predators and prey and each and every
one of us is both and then he tries to
justify what he's doing by saying that
art is selfish
from there she realizes there's nothing
that she can do about it and so she goes
looking for the mysterious woman boro
she met that offered the service of
being able to hurt someone for her if
necessary for all intents and purposes
boro is a witch that can cast spells for
a price by the time lisa gets there
she's willing to pay anything and even
though this is a recipe for disaster you
can see coming from a mile away it was
still pretty freaky when she had to
produce her first payment by puking up a
newborn kitten from there she goes
through a series of spells that
predictably cost her more than what she
gains especially at the beginning it's
going much worse for her than it is for
lou and that is the setup she's lost the
only thing she cares about she wants
revenge against the mentor turned
predator and that drives her to borrow
who you'll learn later is also a
parasite
eventually the curse starts to kick in
and things start to fall apart for luke
but there is a twist along the way
that's important for the ending after
lou loses his son who winds up as one of
boro's zombie minions who she keeps
around and animated with a tadpole
smoothie concoction he finds out where
the witch lives through the incompetent
henchmen he poached from lisa when he
goes to see her instead of trying to
protect lisa she seems happy to help him
there were plenty of red flags before
this but it becomes clear that she wants
something more from lisa than just her
kittens she tells him that she isn't
sure what but that something happened
when they were making the movie and that
he should go look into it he makes his
way to the house in the woods where she
made the film and he meets the actress
who played lucy who's actually missing
her eye and is pretty pissed off at lisa
it turns out that they were lovers and
that she actually financed the short and
in an effort to deliver an amazing
performance she decided to take some
peyote and that led to the creation of
this amazing last scene that everyone
had been hinting at but we hadn't really
seen yet it turns out that she gouged
her own eye out and then ate it on
camera so while everyone thought that
lisa was this fantastic filmmaker it
wasn't special effects or some kind of
directorial wizardry that they were
watching although it does sound like
there was some raw talent on display in
front of and behind the camera what
really made it such a memorable piece
was this incredible sacrifice that mary
made on screen she couldn't remember
what happened and she never saw the film
so before lou left he offered to screen
it for her and gave her his number
finding out that lisa's exploiting this
to get a feature made means that mary
has a huge resentment against her and
heads to la to see what happened to her
eye
as you get to the end you learn that
boro is hundreds of years old and she
did something in the past a long time
ago that she can't take back after
finding out that the body she currently
occupies was once a pretty normal woman
named jennifer who had a husband and
kids you learn that the entity's
longevity is accomplished by jumping
from one body to another
it all started in brazil about 900 years
ago which is interesting because that's
also where lisa spent her childhood boro
started out as a man and one day he
encountered a huge stunning white jaguar
in the forest she described it as like
the mother jaguar a spirit living in an
animal body the jaguar likes the man and
they hook up and she leaves him with
some of her power as a reward he uses
that to become a king and he marries
this great princess and he just has to
give the jaguar an offering of a
sacrifice every so often then his
kingdom comes under threat and he needs
the jaguar again she tells him to go
looking for the poison toad when she
licks it she's able to see where her
enemies are and set a trap but this time
the jaguar wants a big sacrifice in
return she tells the king to bring her
his wife in an attempt to trick the
jaguar he brings a different woman and
that doesn't work out knowing she's been
betrayed the jaguar comes and eats his
wife anyways and then mauls the male
burrow leaving him for dead a young girl
finds him as he's dying alone in the
forest and without even knowing that he
could he uses the last of his strengths
to jump into her body he's been doing
that ever since as far as boro knows the
jaguar was killed by the spanish and
then turned into a couch as soon as lisa
hears that she realizes it's the one
that she saw at the bottom of the ladder
under the trap door that appeared in her
room boro says the jaguar still lives
but is just on the other side and we'll
come back to that
by the time you make it to the finale
lisa has been through a lot she's
produced quite a few kittens including
one that she birthed out of a new
orifice that appeared on her side after
she said she didn't want to puke them
out anymore
she went to jail after eating
psychedelic guinea pig stew she was
choked to death only to be brought back
which was an extra brutal scene because
it was cut with mary watching the film
where you finally see the scene with her
eye for the first time and on top of
that all of her friends code his
girlfriend christine and her movie star
sort of boyfriend roy hardaway all end
up dead she does succeed in ruining
lou's life though after she got him to
snort a worm that she found on a flower
from the vine that was taking over her
entire apartment building it grew inside
his head it damaged both of his optic
nerves and he was left blind after she
removed it before that she had gone to
his hotel intending to kill him but
after he admitted the fact that he took
the movie away because she made him feel
small when she moved his hand off her
thigh she realized that it wasn't really
worth it to kill him while she was
dealing with all that she was constantly
getting stronger and you started to put
it together that what boro really wanted
was her body and that the whole
backstory of lisa's mom leaving when she
was a baby well that's not really what
happened after lisa licked the toad boro
told her that she'd die in about six
hours if she didn't do rituals and sex
and blood magic she does the first with
roy but can't go through with the second
because it involves eating an omelette
with some of code's flesh inside she
refuses saying that she feels like she
traded his life for her movie and while
she walks away the creepy looking shadow
entity that's been popping up comes
right up and touches her the implication
here is that it's protecting her and
removing the poison and when it's done
it attacks borrow leaving her injured
and unconscious on the couch the uncle
comes in to try to finish the job of
killing lisa and she has to use the trap
door to try to get away from him there
she sees the couch again recognizes it's
the jaguar and tells it that she
betrayed you talking about borrow and
says you've been looking for her all
this time then the faceless woman from
her dreams appears and she makes the
connection that part of what's inside of
her comes from the jaguar they talk and
she realizes it's her mother and when
she asks to see her face
you realize it's that entity that she's
seeing even though she doesn't need to
hear it her mother tells her that boro
will betray her she explains the kittens
she says that borrow's using those to
steal her blood from lisa's body without
that she's weak and for lisa to go do
what she needs to do and then come find
her so in the end she does get her
revenge she gets the movie back she
meets with alvin sender he says that
he'll draw up a new contract and she's
guaranteed to direct after everything
she's been through and her talk with the
jaguar she's able to stop boro from
jumping into her body she knows better
than to make a deal with her and is even
able to stop her bringing forth another
kitten and so boro has to settle for
jumping into mary's body which we see
her do instead of sticking around in la
and making the movie lisa nova buys
herself a ticket to brazil where we can
expect that she's going to try to find
her mother i found the show to be an
interesting ride it really was dreamlike
in that it felt like anything could
happen and that was established pretty
early on it feels different from other
shows i've seen on netflix lately and
that's always a good thing i prefer to
see a show that tries to do its own
thing even if it doesn't always work out
brand new cherry flavor isn't perfect
and it did feel a little longer than it
needed to be in places but overall i
thought the unpredictability kept me
engaged even when the story was pretty
straightforward i like the there's a
thing inside of you that you need to get
out and make real the creative process
and how difficult that can be and how
things are set up to keep certain
avenues inaccessible by design at first
the twist with mary felt like it took
away from that a bit but when you hear
lisa say later on that she didn't
remember what happened either and that
she waited for two days before she left
the whole predator and prey angle as it
applies to her sort of breaks down
especially if the implication is that
boro did something to call her to la
after she sensed her i mean there is
some truth to everyone being both
predator and prey but they didn't really
go out of their way to drive that idea
home to me it felt more like a nightmare
process of trying to create something in
a parasitic situation
most of the performances were good but
salazar really carried the whole thing
she's a great fit for the part and it
might not have been as watchable if she
wasn't the lead i think that's a good
place for me to leave it let me know in
the comments if you have any questions
and what you thought of the series
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon